-Performing her debut single,
"Obsessed,"
once again, here's Addison Rae!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
♪ You turned our song down,
baby, what for? ♪
[ Echoing ]
♪ What for? ♪
♪ You had lit candles
on the dashboard ♪
♪♪
♪ Red roses growing
out of our door ♪
♪♪
♪ Wanna say something
you never said before ♪
♪ We were driving down Sunset ♪
♪ You know I love fast cars ♪
♪ Passed by where we first met ♪
♪ Damn, we made it so far ♪
♪ Red eyes from the red light ♪
♪ And that just set the mood ♪
♪ You say you're
obsessed with me ♪
♪ So I took a second ♪
♪ And I said, "Me too" ♪
♪ I'm obsessed with me-e-e ♪
♪ As much as you ♪
♪ Say you'd die for me ♪
♪ I'd die for me-e, too ♪
♪ And if I lost you ♪
♪ I'd still have me ♪
♪ I can't lose ♪
♪ When you say that you're
obsessed with me ♪
♪ Me too ♪
♪ I did my hair
like waves on the beach ♪
[ Echoing ]
♪ On the beach ♪
♪ This dress so tight,
you can't even speak ♪
[ Echoing ]
♪ Can't even speak ♪
♪ My heels so high,
might get a nosebleed ♪
[ Echoing ]
♪ Bleed ♪
♪ Music's so loud,
but I hear your heartbeat ♪
[ Heartbeat ]
[ Echoing ]
♪ I hear your heartbeat ♪
♪ We were driving down Sunset ♪
♪ You know I love fast cars ♪
♪ Passed by where we first met ♪
♪ Damn, we made it so far ♪
♪ Red eyes from the red light ♪
♪ And that just set the mood ♪
♪ You say you're
obsessed with me ♪
♪ So I took a second ♪
♪ And I said, "Me too" ♪
♪ I'm obsessed with me-e-e ♪
♪ As much as you ♪
♪ Say you'd die for me ♪
♪ I'd die for me-e, too ♪
♪ And if I lost you ♪
♪ I'd still have me ♪
♪ I can't lose ♪
♪ When you say that you're
obsessed with me ♪
♪ Me too ♪
♪♪
♪ When you say that you're
obsessed with me ♪
♪ Me too ♪
♪ I'm obsessed with me-e-e ♪
♪ As much as you ♪
♪ Say you'd die for me ♪
♪ I'd die for me-e, too ♪
♪ And if I lost you ♪
♪ I'd still have me ♪
♪ I can't lose ♪
♪ When you say that you're
obsessed with me ♪
♪ Me too ♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]